just like this fixed-wing Bridal reunion
we've been waiting 22 years for the cast
of my best friend's wedding together
again I just thought it was really
clever
and just funny just all the physical
comedy I loved to me so it was it was
magical but the last time I saw it it
kind of made me cry just thinking of you
know a magic that time words and that
summer we knew Julia Rupert Dermot and
Cameron had a chemistry way back when
the iconic rom-com premiere in 1997 is
this love at first sight you believe in
that stuff well we had it we know we had
a day one but here are some things we
didn't know like even though the cast
pre-recorded some parts of this famous
scene they were still surprised on shoot
day the best part of it was when they
started handing out the bids and we were
all like what and the karaoke see where
Cameron looks terrified to sing in
public
yeah she wasn't really acting I was
wanted to run and hide and Dermott
captain kept me there traumatized the
reunion is part of Entertainment
Weekly's first-ever rom-com issue you
can see more of it at ewm like this
moment - the last time I saw you we saw
each other
about 15 years ago a long time anyway
you guys are best friend this lady
yesterday good well by the way this
reunion is so epic that Cameron Diaz
took her Instagram for the first time in
over two years
welcome back as she posted this cast a
selfie with the caption hi so this
happened
[Music]